parmi tous les présidents de la vème
république valéry giscard d'estaing fut
sans doute l'un des plus russophiles en
témoigne sa relation privilégiée avec
leonid brejnev qui était alors le leader
de l'urss
élu en 1974 l'ancien ministre des
finances sous de gaulle va amorcer une
détente des relations franco soviétique
affichant volontiers des positions
personnelles à rebours de ses alliés
giscard va tenter de se trouver une
position de médiateur ce fut notamment
le cas à la fin de l'année 1979 lorsque
les troupes soviétiques entrent en
afghanistan malgré les vives réactions
en europe et aux états unis jusqu'à
rencontre brejnev à varsovie pour
aborder ce sujet il sera le seul
dirigeant occidental à le faire une
rencontre rendue possible par la
relation de confiance nouée entre le
président français et le leader
soviétique lors de leurs différentes
entrevues
les deux hommes ont semble-t-il pu créer
un espace d'échangé sincère se
permettant d'aborder tous les sujets
avec pour même objectif celui de
renforcer la coopération entre la france
et l'union soviétique une relation
diplomatique presque amical quand on lit
les déclarations des deux protagonistes
au fil des années l'illustration de
cette proximité lors d'une visite en
avril 1979 brejnev est malade et malgré
les recommandations de ses médecins il
insiste pour accueillir lui même le
président français à son arrivée à
l'aéroport de moscou lors de la
rencontre
il déclare ceci vous contribuez au
développement des relations entre l'urss
et la france je ne voudrais pas que mon
absence soit interprétée de façon
erronée
vous êtes notre ami passionné d'histoire
et lecteurs assidus des oeuvres de
tolstoï valéry giscard d'estaing va
aussi mettre un point d'honneur à
promouvoir les relations culturelles
entre moscou et paris
on se souviendra par exemple que c'est
sous la présidence de giscard que la
joconde sera exposée à moscou en 1974 en
fait très rare puisque le tableau le
plus célèbre du monde n'a quitté la
france qui à trois reprises au 20e
siècle
en tant qu'ancien chef d'état il
continuait de se rendre à moscou où il
fut notamment reçu en 2015 par vladimir
poutine
sin les deux hommes échangent alors sur
le conflit ukrainien valéry giscard
d'estaing critiques contre la politique
de sanctions menée par les états unis et
l'union européenne défend alors une
désescalade
c'était donc en 2015 et l'ancien
président joue l'apaisement
la situation en ukraine un très
difficile parce que les fans est un pays
composite dans lequel il ya des
communautés humaines historiques
différentes intelligent de savoir
comment ces communautés peuvent-elles
finalement s'organiser pour vivre
ensemble la solution de la force n'est
pas la mode parce que ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre on extermine raoult éliminera
les partenaires donc la solution c'est
de proposer un système d'organisation
politique qui au coup de sifflet mme
dans le monde
dentelles ces deux communautés pourront
vivre facilement
je pense qu'il serait bien qu'en 2015 on
ouvre une discussion sur l'avenir de
l'organisation politique de l'ukraine
avenir pacifique faire le plein ne doit
pas être une menace pour la russie
elles ne vont pas se relâcher volant une
prise de position à l'image finalement
de la politique en oeuvre pendant son
septennat adeptes de la modération et du
dialogue valéry giscard d'estaing aura
assumé des positions tranchées et
parfois à contre-courant le tout lors
d'une période délicate pour les
relations est-ouest